[Musique]
la dette ça a été créée le 1er avril à
donc c'est la direction départementale
de l'emploi du travail et des
solidarités
et cette nouvelle direction est né de la
fusion entre la direction départementale
de la cohésion sociale et l'unité
départementale de la direccte c'est
justement pour réunir dans une même
direction
les compétences en matière d'emploi
d'accompagnement social de lutte contre
la pauvreté et le système de
l'inspection du travail
nous accompagnons les publics les plus
vulnérables pour leur parcours
d'insertion
donc pour leur accès au droit pour leur
accès au logement social pour leur
proposer des solutions d'hébergement
lorsque ces publics sont à la rue nous
travaillons en direction des publics qui
sont demandeurs d'emploi avec
l'opérateur pôle emploi les mixe les
missions locales etc
nous soutenons les entreprises nous les
accompagnons dans ce contexte de
mutations économiques et puis donc les
inspecteurs du travail contrôler les
activités des entreprises protègent les
salariés et conseille également les
entreprises
ce qui va changer en fait pour les
yvelinois c'est qu'il y aura une
coordination renforcée entre les équipes
qui s'occupe de l'accompagnement social
et de l'insertion professionnelle donc
c'est bien évidemment des réponses
beaucoup plus efficace